des croix gammées sur des portraits de
simone veil ou encore une inscription ou
you done sur un magasin au coeur de
paris alors un lien direct n'a pas été
établi avec le mouvement des gilet jaune
mais au fil des manifestations on a
quand même vu des quenelles et des
saluts nazis
benjamin griveaux donc le porte parole
du gouvernement regrette ce grand
défouloir à l'occasion du mouvement des
gilets jaunes en écoute ça se passe
souvent en marge de ces cortèges où on
le sait une part d'extrême gauche et par
d'extrême droite se mêlent provoquent
des violences
ce mouvement sert de grand défouloir
c'est en tout cas sur l'antisémitisme il
ya une libération de la parole
manifestement julia de funès vous êtes
d'accord avec les propos de benjamin
griveaux je suis sur la montée de
l'antisémitisme l'antisémitisme bien sûr
évidemment mais je le redis pas
directement ou vendée gilet jaune ça me
semble faux plusieurs points de vue déjà
l'antisémitisme en france à plusieurs
visages
et encore une fois on ne nomme pas
véritablement le vrai visage de
l'antisémitisme aujourd'hui c'est plus
évidemment l'extrême droite catholique
c'est plus le nazisme de l'europe des
années 30 c'est l'islamisme fondamental
les fondamentalistes islamistes qui sont
excessivement antisémite toutes les
études montrent que ces profits la
commettent des actes antisémites
donc vouloir remettre sur les gilet
jaune cette explication antisémite me
semble encore une fois un alibi
deuxièmement vouloir expliquer justifier
la montée de l'antisémitisme chercher
des responsables des causes explicatives
à l'antisémitisme c'est nier ce qu'est
l'antisémitisme c'est vouloir
rationaliser de lits rationalise à bhl
c'est à dire la haine
le mouvement de haine pour les noms ne
rationalise pas un sentiment une passion
donc encore une fois vouloir expliquer
sa déduire sa du mouvement des gilet
jaune c'est vraiment nier ce qu'est
l'antisémitisme personne d'autre que
d'antisémite des responsables de son
antisémitisme et dernière chose la
logique des gilets jaunes c'est pourquoi
je ne le relie pas il ya une
concomitance mais il n'y a pas un lien
de cause à effet pourquoi parce que la
logique du gilet jaune au tout début
utile une logique d'intérêt vouloir
gagner en pouvoir d'achat c'était une
logique rationnelle
simplement cette logique dé gilet jaune
à dériver aussi vers une logique
passionnel qui est la jalousie la haine
de là
richesse et c'est pour ça enfin le lit
sf la question du sf le prouve
ça n'apporterait rien économiquement aux
individus ou ont même à la france
simplement en termes de symbole c'est
énorme donc on est dans une logique
passionnel et c'est là que les deux se
rejoignent et se et converger vers une
logique de n1 n2 race pour l'un haine de
classe a pour l'autre olivier duhamel
d'accord pas d'accord avec lui à
financer partiellement je pense que
c'est indiscutable monde le sait qui a
tort de nouvel antisémitisme depuis des
années des années qui vient de
l'islamisme radical il a absolument
aucun doute là dessus mais il ya aussi
la persistance voire la renaissance d'un
antisémitisme d'extrême droite
et ça c'est le pôle premier bémol c'est
qu'il n'a pas que celui qui vient de
surgir
oui enfin de jeu extrêmement je le mets
dans la première catégorie
la deuxième chose c'est que oui vous
avez raison de certaines fêtes se
recoupent parfois mes pattes strictement
vous avez raison et la deuxième chose
c'est que je pense qu'il ya quand même
il est attesté qu'il y a alors peut-être
parce que justement ces gens sont
présents avec les gilet jaune
mais dans ce qui reste des gilets jaunes
parce qu'en plus on dit les gilet jaune
léger jaune il était pas de 400 milles
et maintenant ils sont cinquante mille 1
donc ça veut dire qu'il y en a quand
même une immense partie qui est plus
dans le mouvement et dans la
protestation et dans ceux qui restent il
y en a à l'évidence eux qui ont eu des
expressions antisémite
du coup je veux juste citer des fines
leur vie leur rabbin libéral ce matin
sur europe 1 je rêve d'imaginer que ces
gens qui manifestent semaine après
semaine puisse dire pas en mon nom et
c'est vrai qu'on attend toujours de la
part des différentes figures connues des
usages joueurs des condamnations radical
de ce genre de dérive dégueulasse je
vous donne la parole tout utah tous les
deux mais juste pour compléter on va
écouter aussi alexis corbière député la
france insoumise alexis corbière qui lui
parle d'une
en réponse à benjamin griveaux parle une
instrumentalisation politique
je peux comprendre l'émotion mais quand
je vois que le porte parole du
gouvernement en profite au passage pour
en mettre une petite louche comme quoi
il y aurait un lien entre gilet jaune et
manifestations je trouve ça a redit je
ne crois pas que la croix gammée sur la
mairie du xième soit en lien que la
manifestation du gilet jaune idem pour
le bagad stein le la monstruosité dans
le sémitisme est tel que franchement on
n'est pas obligé d'en rajouter parce que
c'est pas utile ce genre d'
instrumentaliser
allez si ses notes alexis corbière lui
pas de condamnation c'est très direct et
très une frappe je te laisse parler de
haine moi ce qui me frappe dans ce pays
en ce moment c'est la montée je dirais
des haines et peut-être qui se
cristallise et encore c'est pas une
cause mais qui ce qu'ils trouvent à se
cristalliser s'est créé autour de cette
affaire du gilet jaune mais enfin ça
fait quand même très longtemps qu'on
n'avait pas vu et je veux venir après
l'antisémitisme cette haine des pauvres
contre les riches des riches contre les
pauvres on entend des gens qui à fait
raisonnable il faut tirer dans le tas
des manifestants contre les policiers
des policiers contre les manifestants et
parfois c'est tout à fait explicables
enfin on sent qu un espèce de truc de
choses qui bouillonne et souvent le pire
et dans ce pire il y à la haine
antisémite
il ya aussi les anti chrétiennes le
plein d'église là qui sont faits
profanées ces temps ci quand on parle va
nous en tout cas on en parle les deux
mais ce que je veux dire on sent qu'il
ya quelque chose qui qui qui qui
bouillonne et dans ce bouillon il y à la
laine antisémites alors fort
heureusement il n'y a plus de parti
antisémite
il ya des groupuscules autour de soral
dieudonné de dégoût mienne qui avait la
liste combattre le judaïsme politique
visage et de se présenter à biloxi multi
alors de ce 10 mai qui retrouve ses
chemins finalement et ça n'est pas une
excuse d'une butte contre le système à
l'heure mais laissez les riches et les
puissants et qu'on va alors on va
similaire dira macron c'est la mort
sociale et rock et donc rothschild la
data donc tout ça tout ça va se mélanger
alors comment dire je pense que
factuelles manquant griveaux dit qu'on
trouve ça dans l'eau tour des cortèges
il a actuellement pas tort puisque
puisque tout tous ces gens qui restent
et qui fait mention les plumes les plus
radicalisées parfois les plus dingues au
bail parmi eux il ya des antisémites
je pense que là où il aurait grand tort
c'est donner l'impression d'
instrumentaliser cette affaire de
l'antisémitisme pour lutter contre les
jaunes c'est absolument légitime que le
gouvernement condamne ali gilet jaune
que commandent des manifestations dijon
mais je crois qu'il ne faut surtout pas
donner l'impression d'utiliser cesser
ses manifestations réel d'antisémitisme
au profit d'un autre combat ce qui par
ailleurs peut avoir ses raisons
parce que ça serait les détourner et
donné des armes au sein par exemple aux
antisémites en disant 'vous voyez ils
sont contre vous vous aussi les pauvres
parce que vous voyez ils sont contre
nous donc il faut faire très attention à
ne pas instrumentaliser ce label
christophe daulmerie là je vais parler
plutôt comme historiens c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui regarde les faits un
simplement un l'inscription juden n'a
pas du tout été fait pendant ni en marge
ni autour du cortège a été faite pendant
la nuit
d'accord qui a précédé la manifestation
donc deuxièmement on ne sait absolument
pas pour le tag de simone pelle qui
d'ailleurs dirais moi je regarde ça me
frappe toujours cette photo parce que je
l'entends dire nazis au petit pied
entend répondre
et puis je dirais que la hausse des
actes antisémites ne date pas du tout du
mouvement de gilet jaune quand vous
regardez les statistiques c'est quelque
chose de bien à l'intérieur et en fait
dans la gravité des actes ni mohamed
merah ni coulibaly n'était jamais la vie
des gilet jaune des élus vrai ou faux
de la part du délégué interministériel
qu'il y avait eu un mac croix dans
l'accroissement qu'on a indiqué de 74%
il était particulièrement soutenu les
derniers mois de l'année donc pendant
ses rêves j'ai déjà au gabon il était
parti en fumée vous regardez c'est une
tendance longue quand même c'est à dire
même s'il ya eu pendant deux ans et
l'acte antisémite une part qu est ce que
cela recouvre
il ya quand même une différence entre
tué une vieille dame juive et m m une
inscription je crois quand même qu'il
faut il faut il faut se rappeler de ça
et jusqu'à présent ils allaient le
préfet de la drogue qui d'aussi un grand
expert de ces questions a montré que
tous les actes graves depuis exactement
20 ans et comme sur beaucoup de sujets
sont liées essentiellement à ce que
disait juillet tunnel c'est à dire
l'antisémitisme d'origine islamiste ou
les actes et notamment ilan et mieux je
vous rappel n'a pas été pas
malheureusement pas que islamistes au
sens dj sneak communautaire au sens de
communauté d'origine arabe
aujourd'hui le juif qui les français
juifs qui ont peur pour leurs enfants
parce que les enfants se font attaquer
dans la rue parce qu'il porte une kippa
il y en a beaucoup et il y en a de plus
en plus et beaucoup ont quitté les
quartiers vous habitez c'est parce que
la cohabitation avec les communautés
d'origine
mais dira parce que mon but gmail ne se
fait pas donc c'est malheureusement plus
grave que de l'islamisme c'est presque
parfois culturel et et pour les français
juifs c'est ça la vraie aujourd'hui de
vraies souffrances et sans doute la
vraie cause de départ beaucoup plus que
les gilets jaunes et même que
l'islamisme en tant que data terrorisant
tout cas elle devra dit qu'elle est
jamais là olivier duhamel a parfaitement
raison c'est vrai que et vous avez aussi
totalement raison c'est vrai que je
crois que c'est ce contexte général
j'aime pas du tout l'expression de
libération de la parole d'une expression
quelle fut leur mission deux qui
s'étaient réfugiées ça veut dire que la
parole quand elle est libre est horrible
enfin je veux dire cette expression elle
demanderait vraiment être travaillée on
entend un peu ça ça d'ailleurs remis aux
le sujet de l'anonymisation aussi sur
les réseaux sociaux
absolument c'est beaucoup plus ce genre
de phénomène et là franchement je
reconnais tous d'accord alors je crois
même brut d'accord avec alexis corbière
là faut faire quand même très attention
à l'instrumentalisation politique
ce qu'on appelle en rhétorique là je
reviens la rhétorique une entreprise de
disqualification c'est à dire que vous
allez allez antisémitisme c'est fini les
gilets jaunes quoi vous êtes encore bien
le même flux de l'instrumentalisation
quelques réactions sur ce sujet elles
sont nombreuses
d'abord la réponse à la question que
vous posez elle était assise formulées
sur twitter des gilet jaune nous reste
il l'antisémitisme vous êtes 61% à dire
que non alors coach nous répond
antisémitisme à mettre en lien avec la
recrudescence des saccages dans les
églises chrétiennes vous avez fait
allusion tous les deux effectivement
elle figure on en parle ce matin clown
ou 17 et vit dans l'extrême droite est
très présente notamment dans les manifs
sur lyon par exemple elle était
dominante jusqu'à samedi
et quand l'ultra gauche arrive nous
assistons à des combats de rue très
violent sur lefigaro.fr bonito nous dit
il me semble que les études du nombre
d'actes antisémites par mois montre que
l'augmentation n'est pas lié au gilet
jaune
vous disiez olivier duhamel que les
derniers mois de 2010 huit montrent une
plus nette augmentation dans les
derniers mois de l'année brownie tôt à
mon avis il ya une montée des
communautarismes qui s'accompagne d'une
haine des communautés monsieur babineau
complète la haine fait partie de chaque
mouvement social et ou politiques de par
le monde on a juste perdu l'habitude en
france
et la palme d'or mais c'est vrai qu'il
ya quelque chose de dramatique
pas d'ironie terrible de l'histoire de
ce top 14 à elle ne fait pas partie de
chaque mouvement politique la phrase
c'est ça c'est la haine la haine fait
partie de chaque mouvement social et ou
politiques qui me nombre d'appareils
commandés enfin tout cas la neige fait
partie de la nature humaine
sa balle est donc dans ses expressions
violentées dans ces combats
il ya souvent des de ce que je veux
c'est ce qui est ce qui me paraît d'une
espèce de tous dit ronnie dramatique de
l'histoire c'est que et j'en fais pas
porter la responsabilité
une personnellement à maquereau que ce
quinquennat qui devait être un moment de
réconciliation en tout cas dans cete ça
comme ça que les choses avaient été
présentés et vendus aujourd'hui et le
lieu de cette exacerbation des haines
c'est quand même quelque chose de
nouveau hissé qu'avec avec la montée et
des succès croissant des populismes oui
des démocraties qui étaient relativement
paisibles relativement consensuelle le
débat politique est devenue d'une
virulence extrême si on compare salvini
avec tous ceux qui étaient au pouvoir
avant en italie si on compare le trump
avec tous les présidents qui l'ont
précédé
c'est juste sans commune mesure c'est
vrai les skis frappant je crois que
c'est julien qui disiez c'est que je
m'aperçois quand on regarde les réseaux
sociaux des gens extrêmement bien sous
tous rapports comme on dit moi je suis
étonné pro ou anti ma chronique par
exemple deviennent 24 totalement gilet
jaune dans leur mode d'expression des
gens qui eussent te ment matin un
français parfait était d'une modération
total maintenant se met à insulter et ça
ça parait être l'air du temps c'est pas
les gilet jaune ça c'est l'air du temps
c'est et ça ça m'inquiète davantage
c'est à dire que même les gens qui sont
quand même chargé justement jacques un
peu comme nous de ramener les choses à
l'analyse etc sont entrés dans le
processus
un petit peu de délire verbal
je sais les vidéos elles conviennent sur
l'équation peut être simpliste mais que
certains font entre extrême gauche
antisionisme antisémitisme cas c'est à
moi que vous parler pendant que j'avais
peur
non ça va peut-être beaucoup moins que
vous cher monsieur
non non je m'en dire ce sont des cercles
qui se recoupent
mais ce ne sont pas des ensembles qui
coïncide totalement c'est que vous avez
de l'extrême gauche qui n'est pas
antisémite et vous avez de
l'antisémitisme dans des groupes
d'extrême gauche
vous avez massivement l'antisionisme a
été utilisée massivement c'est certain
comme prétexte pour masquer
l'antisémitisme parce que ça faisait
moins condamnable de dire qu'on était en
signe antisioniste et antisémite mais
vous avez encore même si c'est peut-être
devenu résiduelles des antisionistes
ailleurs y compris les juifs
antisionistes qui sont évidemment pas
antisémite mais ce que c'est pas une
explication à l'antisémitisme devant
lieu française en l'histoire enfin de
france il ya une tradition
d'antisémitisme dans notre lit mais de
droite catholique a une feuille
tradition d'antisémitisme de gauche et
d'ultra gauche prodon etc
il ya toujours eu ça donc c'est ça
traverse toute l'histoire de france
je pense quand même que historiquement
et c'est un des grands mérites et en
convient c'est que cette tradition n'est
plus porté par personne de façon ouverte
et officiels à part quelques 6 crime
portée mais elles étaient totalement
interdites inaudible inacceptable dont
nous pouvait-on penser inexistante
pendant les cinquante années qui ont
suivi la deuxième guerre mondiale
et ça c'était il ya quelques histrion
qu'ils le fassent par deux sera le
dieudonné s'est tramé ya aujourd'hui pas
de parti politique mais que une cet
antisémitisme la française reste dans
notre fil de notre histoire
oui mais pour autant et je rejoins ce
que ce que disait christophe la réalité
de l'antisémitisme
sans nier celui là qui est à
d'antisémitisme inscrit dans notre
histoire
sans nier suis là je crois que la
réalité main très majoritaire et ultra
majoritaire de l'antisémitisme dont
aujourd'hui sont victimes les français
juifs c'est l'antisémitisme d'origine
musulmane
julie à un dernier mot sur le côté
justement on le disait je regardais un
chiffre les départs de juifs en europe
qui décide 38% selon l agence des droits
fondamentaux de l'union européenne
dernier étude en date 38 % des personnes
en europe de confession juive ont pensé
à quitter leur pays
vous verrez c'est fou mais ce qui est
très angoissant et c'est ça qui est
terrible c'est que jamais une logique
d'intérêt n'a créé des guerres tant
qu'on parlait de pouvoir d'achat tant
qu'on parle du prix du pétrole
on ne fait pas des gains on ne tue pas
on ne commet pas des actes terribles
dès qu'on rentre dans une logique
passionnel donc de haine c'est là que
les pires crimes peuvent être commis
évidemment et c'est là que seuls les
populismes où les nationalismes on l'a
on a l'impression que seuls ces
populisme son audible parce qu'ils
répondent avec le même langage avec la
même violence et c'est pour ça que c'est
inquiétant de se dire on est rentré dans
une logique de nl s'agrègent toutes les
haines raciales
sociale tous que de classe de race tout
ce que vous voulez s'agrègent et donc la
réponse ce sera quoi est ce que ce sera
pas nécessairement un populisme dans un
extrême dernière réaction sur le sujet
de la part de nos internautes sentiment
qui nous disent qu'ils nous dit pardon
je pense que beaucoup de petits objets
s'ils profitent de la situation pour
taguer faire le buzz c'est triste ils
savent qu'ils vont faire la une est
salée grise et monsieur babineau qui est
toujours sur l'idée de haine dans les
mouvements sociaux il ya toujours eu de
la haine c'est juste qu'avec les réseaux
sociaux on a des amplificateurs